the five best chess moves of MVL and I'm
so happy to be doing this video this is
only gonna be on people playing in the
candidates and mvo has got that place I
think well deserved even though he got
it because someone else pulled out now
MVL is a brilliant player whilst looking
for games I came across many tats called
brilliant C's so I had a wealth of
examples to pick from we're gonna look
at five of his best now please enjoy
please try to find the moves and let me
know which one is your favorites on to
example number one in this first example
White has just played Bishop to d5 check
now most mere mortals would be right
okay I'm in check I've got to move my
King out of check they'd be thinking I
cannot take that bishop because my
knight is pinned but this is MVL and he
comes up with an incredibly imaginative
Queen sacrifice here he's probably one
of the main guys in the world who
sacrifices his Queen more than anyone
else saw I saw this when doing my
research for this YouTube video and here
he plays Knight takes d5 and the idea of
this is after Bishop takes the eight
Knight takes c3 attacking the Queen
white recaptures black recaptures here
and MVL has only a rook and a bishop for
the Queen but the bishops are extremely
good lvl has some great open lines to
work on and White's King is quite weak
very nice vision showing great
understanding of the game and after some
more moves Queen d2 pawn takes here
opening up the e-file and now taking
advantage of that open file King F one
Bishop takes g4 you can see the black
pieces are flooding in and to become
such a great player you have to be brave
and this shows that nvl is well capable
of being brave example number two mvo
with black pieces here
rook d5 just been played remember you
can try to find MBL's mousse and this is
another case of brilliant foresight what
would you do here pause if you need to
Queen takes d5 another Queen sacrifice
I reckon that MVL has some grudge
against the Queen you know maybe when
he's a small child you know going
through the streets of Paris in his cot
a nasty Queen fell from the sky landed
on his head and it left some Freudian
mark on his subconscious the game
continued pawn takes d5 Bishop to e5 and
the point again is that all his
remaining pieces are raving the Queen
runs away
Bishop h2 and now rook h8 and just every
black piece plays a part he really
understands how the pieces do coordinate
and this gives him a great chance in the
candidates in my opinion the game
continued with lvl repeating the
position once showing who's boss and now
a very clever move to distract the Queen
away from the King and he plays III
going for the win if the knight can get
into e3 he'll be laughing but after a
couple more moves it becomes clear that
he's in a great position with that a
pawn
1 square away from queening so mvo and
Queens
don't put them next to each other you
might have a problem that's one thing
I'm learning so far sometimes the best
things in life are short and sweet can
you think of any examples that in life
well we have an example on the chess
board here lvl clearly has an attack
with free pieces very actively placed
and he now finds the best way to finish
things off remember pause if you can't
find it
rook to g7 and this rook can be captured
in actual fact nepo one of his rivals in
the candidates resigned here the fret is
taken on h7 with mate and if it is
captured now rook f7 Czech gains a
deadly
and next move either the rook or queen
will capture on h7 deliver and checkmate
quite a simple tactic but one that is I
would say reasonably strange put on a
rook on an empty square where it could
be captured and like I said some of
these simple ideas are visually the most
pleasing this next example again shows
how mvl can coordinate his pieces to
create magic over a chessboard his
pieces again are raving around the board
the black king is a little bit of a weak
place Knights and Queen very good
attackers normally but how did MVL force
the win here one of my favorite moves of
the whole whole lot this one can you see
it
rook to d7 like the last example the
rook dies into a square where it can
seemingly be taken by numerous pieces in
this example but the real idea behind
this beautiful move is to try and get
rid of this bishop which is blocking the
ephah his opponent fellow Frenchman Igor
and the TAF now play Bishop takes d7 but
after Knight takes D 7 check with the
idea of flicking the Queen to h8 King to
g8 the knight comes back King to f8
there's one more killer move can you see
it Knight to h5 and the real reason
behind this tact it becomes clear
there's no good way to stop Queen to h8
checkmate the game now continued G takes
h5 and of course the Queen slid in mvl
had a bit of his cross on and delivered
check mate in style a very nice play
there and like the last example it's
this little move putting a rook on an
empty square opening up lines opening up
the e-file that wins the game in this
case you can discuss other variations in
the comments below this next example is
quite beautiful I think the pieces on
the board seem like they've just been
thrown on there by some modern artist
we'll have a spray of pieces over there
with a piece of a piece over there
as you can see there's a porn here how
did that get there the material
imbalance is very strange black has a
queen and a rook but white is the
threatening of the Queen and the rook so
anything here is still possible but MVL
finds a very nice way to calculators his
way through these complications can you
find the best move now
it is rook takes f2 and this is really a
great example of how what top players do
okay they're attacked a normal human
might move the Queen and allow the rook
to be captured but top players will
always try to find the most active
solution and rook takes f2 is trying to
get rid of the two rooks
two Queen the b-pawn here it's a queen
the b-pawn here and one line that
demonstrates how strong this is is rook
takes Queen and now rook takes rook
check and in this position we can just
take this guy here and the pawn will
Queen again you can discuss other
variations in the comments below but
this rook takes over two is just a
really beautiful bolt from the blue here
and a very nice demonstration and that
last line after rook takes Queen maybe
even stronger his Bishop takes rook you
know this is another another way that
should win eventually with the rook
sliding in here so a lovely sense of
vision the game continued Knight g5 but
after Bishop g3 this Queen can still not
really be captured and there's a threat
of Queen h6 so beautiful tactics
remember yell who's as good as anyone
else in the world when it comes to
tactics nice bitters unis sake wash own
on the board there and NVL proving he's
tactically very astute and just as good
as anyone else in the world I hope he
does brilliantly in the candidates is a
lovely guy very humble and an extremely
talented chess player remember to like
this video and remember to subscribe to
chess comm leave your comments below
good bad or ugly I'm used to
the more I have to look in the mirror
for example every day and I'll try to
catch up with your comments at some
point thanks goodbye for now